арка дружби народів
у києві символи даня україни та росії
аркою та алла дружби не травня 2 став ці
українська та російська будинки волосся про
партнерства про далекий від 90 інший урок
то після євромайдан впади в криму і
агресії Росії про дружбу воді говорить
і про стане стильним проектом став і дні
києва у Москві
вузлів не 2013 . депутати київради тепер
ви вирішили формально вигляд молодість
перетвори
і все так ведіть наші колишні до
старший брат і те
стежка розлучався з ще пов'язана
процедури розлучення я питиму лимонад
і
ідею Петро i move та марка його Віталій
кличко
давайте вигляд вертуг азат і 13 уроку
проучи м'яко вкажіть складні повернутися
на та політичних етносу на між
україна юта російську федерацію
брати між пологами шляхом війна і
койни бачите
місця про оборотність проти і через
візиту делегації проведення спинних
спортивних і культурних заходи а так вже
про windows виглядом але нині тигони травня
думка цієї він сюди дружба з Москви
розділилося а резервати 1 значить таки
може бути дружно сумки з державою аресу
у Москві з dutch основні агресор
Російської Федерації колоди на
сьогоднішній етап цифри зрозумілі, а потім
вже калли в ладно йому ззаду пачино
тягнуся можна його нала що ти шкода москви
і жадібних вирішено спр і воду подалі від нього
побратимства з києвом нахвалював між
консерви сійський стілець і кидати про
поставлятися корисному я не особливо його
вид шивої у нас вбили дно сіни місць по
брат ними там удару позіхання від них видно
примушу себе дощ з покину я думаю що
краще супер красиво чайна усу бойову для
поросячий громадян це важливо
а би був та добрий мішки mesh краї нам
це місцям і проблеми з твариною вище
корінні виду кидається на простих
людях
крим киева позування догляд про
партнерство з російською та місцями
побратимом і ж
инете і вали хмельницьке то
ivano-frankivsk